problema número 154 una piscina vacía
está siendo llenada con agua a una razón
constante y le toma ocho horas llenarse
a tres quintas partes de su capacidad
cuánto tiempo más le tomará llenarse en
su totalidad
nos dicen que tentada para llenarse tres
quintas partes de la piscina le lleva
ocho horas eso es lo mismo que tener 340
vos
de piscina por ahora otra forma de verlo
es que si se tarda 8 horas
en llenar tres quintas partes
o lo que queremos saber es cuántas
sordas tardará en llenarse las dos
quintas partes que faltan dividimos todo
entre cinco y estos elementos se van y
nos queda que 8 entre 3 es igual a x
entre 2
y aquí si aplicamos la multiplicación
cruzada y nos queda que 16 es igual a 3x
por lo tanto x va a ser igual a 16 entre
que en términos de fracciones es igual a
cinco enteros un tercio es decir son
cinco horas con 20 minutos 20 minutos es
la tercera parte de una hora que es
nuestra opción de siguiente problema 155
un número positivo x es multiplicado por
2 y este producto se divide entre 3 si
la raíz positiva de la raíz cuadrada de
esta operación es igual a x cuál es el
valor de x lo que nos dicen es que
tenemos 2x entre 3
todo esto con su raíz cuadrada y esto es
igual a equis y también nos dicen que x
es mayor que 0 es un número positivo
elevamos al cuadrado a ambos lados nos
va a quedar 2x entre 3 es igual a equis
cuadrada multiplicamos por 3 ambos lados
nos quedan 2x igual a 3 x cuadrada y
como x es mayor que 0 podemos dividir
ambos lados entre x y nos queda que 2 es
igual a 3 x
por lo que x es igual a dos tercios que
es la opción d
otra forma de realizar esto es dejarlo
de esta forma en esta parte dejarlo como
3 x cuadrada menos 2 x igual a cero y
factorizar lo de manera que nos quede 3x
menos 2 x x igual a 0 y esto nos hubiera
indicado si 3 x 20 ó x es igual a 0 pero
ya nos dicen que x es mayor que 0 pero
de cualquier manera hubiéramos llegado a
la misma conclusión 2 texas
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 156
un tanque contiene 10.000 galones de una
solución que tiene 5% de cloruro de
sodio 2500 galones de agua se evaporan
del tanque qué porcentaje de cloruro de
sodio habrá en la solución resultante
los datos son 10 mil galones
galones de la solución que tiene 5% de
cloruro de sodio que es lo mismo que sal
y nos dicen que de estos 10.000 galones
2.500 galones de agua se evaporan
galones de agua
se evaporan y la sal o el cloruro de
sodio no se evapora ese permanece cual
es el 5% de 100 bueno el 5% de 100 va a
ser 5
5 de 1000 va a ser 50 el 5% de 10.000 va
a ser 500 así que este 5% va a ser igual
a 500 galones de sal si perdemos 2 mil
500 galones de agua el cloruro de sodio
que queda va a estar ahora en una nueva
proporción va a ser estos 500 galones de
cloruro de sodio que quedan entre 10.000
menos 2500 son 7.500 7500
esto quitamos estos ceros nos queda que
esto es igual a 5 entre 75 que es igual
a 1 entre 15 si multiplicamos 5 el
numerador y el denominador nos da 5
entre 75 para sacarlo con forma de
porcentaje va a ser 15 entre 11.00
aquí necesito un cero para bajar el 100
y voy a multiplicar esto por 6 6 por 5
36 por 16 39 100 menos 90 es 10
bajaremos otro cero y aquí se repetiría
este seis indefinidamente entonces el
porcentaje es de 6.67 aproximadamente
por ciento aquí redondeamos el punto 6
666 y esta es nuestra opción de veamos
el siguiente problema número 157
x 5 y 16 x es igual a menos 3 porque
cuál es el valor de ella vamos a
sustituir esta segunda ecuación en esta
de acá así que si tengo x5 y y aquí es
igual a menos 3 y los sustituyó aquí
menos tres más 5 y igual a 16 esto es
igual a 2 igual a 16 por lo que lleva a
ser igual a 16 entre 288 que es nuestra
opciones
siguiente problema
problema número 158 un comité se compone
de m mujeres de mujeres y h hombres
tres mujeres y dos hombres se agregan al
comité y una persona se elige
aleatoriamente de entre todo el comité
cuál es la probabilidad de que la
persona elegida sea una mujer bueno
entonces tenemos que son mujeres
h hombres y para ver la proporción de
mujeres o la probabilidad de mujeres
entre el total de personas del comité
son el número de mujeres más 3 que se
agregaron entre el total que es el
número de mujeres más 3 más el número de
hombres que había
+ 2 esto es igual no simplificamos m3 /
m
más h 5 y esta es la opción
y dejamos el siguiente problema
problema número 159 si el producto de
los enteros w x y z es 770 y si uno es
menor que w y doblegó es menor que xy x
es menor que y si es menor que z cuál es
el valor de doble un maceta entonces lo
que nos dicen es que la multiplicación
de v w x x x
por z es igual a 770 770 y cada uno de
ellos es mayor que el otro en este orden
nos preguntan cuál es doble un maceta
veamos si podemos hacer una
factorización de primos que presiento
que esto es lo que quieren que hagamos
s 770 lo puedo factorizar como 7 por 11
77 por 10 todo esto me va a dar 770
puedo factorizar este 10 como 12 por 5
me queda 7 por 11 por 2 por 5 todo esto
me da el 770 y tengo 4 números que son
mayores que 1 y que son diferentes si yo
los ordenó del menor al mayor 2 5 7 11
puedo decir que este 2 es igual a la w
el 5 es igual a la equis
7 es igual a 10 y 11 es igual a z lo que
me preguntan de w z es igual a 2 más
11 igual a 13 13 es mi opción b
siguiente problema esta figura muestra
una jardinera que está centrada en o y
tiene un camino circular de 3 metros de
ancho cuál es el área del camino en
metros cuadrados
estos son metros estos son metros y aquí
lo que tenemos que hacer es calcular el
área de esta circunferencia grande y
restarle el área de la circunferencia
pequeña como hacemos esto bueno tenemos
que encontrar el radio del círculo más
grande y nos dicen que el radio de aquí
acá es 8 y este ancho es 3 83 es 11 así
que nuestro radio del círculo más grande
el área que está afuera afuera
spears por radio el cuadrado y el radio
que es 11 al cuadrado es 121
el área de adentro área adentro
el radio es de 8 va a ser su área pin
por radio al cuadrado el radio 28 8 por
8 64
para encontrar esta área de esta
diferencia de este caminito es el área
de afuera afuera
afuera - el área de adentro
dentro
qué es 121 pink menos 64 esto nos da
igual 57
y esta es la opción de y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo